Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie
So huge news, George R.R. Martin was at a convention this past weekend and read from new
material from "Winds of Winter".
So he revealed some big details about Briennes backstory that made her that much more badass.
So, just careful for spoilers if you don't want to know anything about Brienne.
Brienne is one of those characters that's been really put upon as she tells her history.
There was an episode where she was talking to Pod  explaining how they called her, "Brienne the Beauty", as an insult.
Because even though you look at her right now and she's really big, really strong, total badass
You have to remember that she's probably been that tall since she was about 15 or 16, maybe even younger than that.
It takes boys just a little big longer to catch up at that age, so if you think she's taller than say like Ser Jaime now
than imagine how big the difference was when they were teenagers.
So as she tells it, as a child her father tried to marry her off 3 times just like you would a traditional lady from a noble house
but it led to 3 broken engagements just because no one would have her.
... and you could imagine how bad things got when she would just embarrass people that would get into fights with her.
Like she'd spar with some of the other nobles and just kick their asses
So you could imagine like all those young noble boys wounded pride just saying awful awful things about her, her entire life.
So as much as that sucks, she's become this amazing badass on the TV show.
She's still a badass in the books, the show has just pushed her to the forefront a little bit more.
She's a little bit more of a background character in the books.
But here's the really cool thing that George R.R. Martin did this past weekend:
If you've read the Dunc and Egg series, Ser Duncan the Tall is named the protector of young Egg, Aegon the Fifth
who becomes the future King of Westeros.
So that series is all about their adventures together like this really giant hedge knight and the future King of Westeros just palling around over the Seven Kingdoms.
But of the new material George R.R. Martin read, he named Brienne the descendant of Ser Duncan the Tall.
So just a really easy fix to make a character that everyone already loves that has a pretty terrible backstory, have a really amazing backstory.
Oh, like you think she had it bad but she comes from this amazing lineage.
So just think of all the amazing things she's gonna do.
Hopefully she makes it to season 8.
She's one of those characters that definitely throws herself in the line of fire.
So given that we have several characters now that all have Valyrian swords, including the newest, Samwell.
It would be such a disappointment if she didn't get to use Oathkeeper at some point to just Hulk out on some White Walkers.
But let me know in the comments what do you think about Brienne being the descendant of Ser Duncan the Tall.
If you haven't read the books, he's kind of like the most famous knight in the history of Westeros. At least at this point.
The show has actually invoked a little bit of Dunc and Egg.
You may have missed it briefly but Maester Aemon talks about Egg as he's dying.
"Egg, Egg mothers calling you."
Egg, from the Dunc and Egg series was one of Maester Aemons brothers. You have to remember, Maester Aemon is very very old.
It was a really touching, sweet moment.
Especially what happened to his family later in life. At the end of his life that King Aegon died in what was called the Tragedy at Summerhall.
Side note: It's actually one of the instances that people point to when they say that Targaryens, not all Targaryens are immune to fire.
Because they died in a giant house fire. Like almost his entire family was wiped out.
The really cool thing about Dunc and Egg is that George R.R. Martin has actually pointed to it as his leading choice for a spinoff should HBO decide to do a Game of Thrones spinoff.
I think they definitely want to, but Dan and Dave are so set on finishing what they're doing right now...
... getting through the next season that they haven't announced anything about a spinoff yet, whether it's going to have different producers...
... but George R.R. Martin is like, "full steam ahead" he's like two thumbs up definitely go for it, do a spinoff.
So if we get a spinoff it will probably be the adventures of Dunc and Egg.
George R.R. Martin said that he's going to continue to write Dunc and Egg.
He'll continue to write expanded material. So there will be plenty more new awesome people that he introduces
But as of right now it's just that Ser Duncan the Tall is the perfect ideal of the person that Brienne is trying to become.
All I ever wanted to do was become a knight she says.
That's why I've been a little dissapointed with Jaime  this season so far.
Yeah, he's been on a tear, we got to see that amazing Mad King, Kingslayer flashback.
But I think it's especially disappointing for book readers because in the books he's on a slightly more redemptive arc.
In the show, thus far, at least this far in the season up to episode 6 makes it seem like he's learned nothing-- like none of Briennes good qualities have rubbed off on him.
That's why I'm just waiting for someone to write fan-fiction where Tormund and Jaime fight for Briennes affections.
But remember Brienne will eventually head down to the Riverlands to try and secure the help of the Blackfish in Sansas quest to retake Winterfell.
Jaime is being sent to the Riverlands at the head of the Lannister Army to try and get rid of the Blackfish.
So they will definitely be meeting up with each other
... and for those of you that are wondering where Bronn is, he actually appears in the trailer briefly here putting Pod in a choke-hold like, "Oh my god I can't believe I haven't seen you in so long."
So Bronn is still around it's just that Jaime only just mentioned him in the previous episode when he was like I'm going to get Bronn, we're going to assassinate the High Sparrow...
... and Cersei just pumped the brakes on it hardcore.
Just do not do that.
So I'm hoping Briennes able to Joffrey slap some sense into Jaime, but it kind of looks like Jaimes determined to be a douche bag this season.
So you guys let me know in the comments:
What do you think is going to happen when Jaime and Brienne meet up and they're at odds.
She's trying to get the help of the Blackfish.
Jaimes trying to get rid of the Blackfish.
But in related news my next Game of Thrones video will be the Q&A. So I'll be pulling questions from my episode 6 video as well as this video.
So just leave all your questions about episode 6, about Dunc and Egg, about Brienne.
Anything you guys want to talk about. I feel like we're mostly going to be talking about Coldhands but theres a couple other really big things going on.
While you guys wait for my next video to post you can click here for my episode 6 video and you can click here to learn about how the actor that plays Ramsay Bolton wants to die on the show.
He talked a little bit about how he wants to go.
So thank you so much for watching, everybody let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight.